on today's show we take a deep dive into
adhd
especially with teenagers we also talked
to a
new wife and an expectant mother on how
to draw boundaries with her mom
stay tuned what's up
hey what's going on man this is john
with the dr john deloney show
and i just came in kind of high pitched
almost like i'm going through puberty
that was a little bit much everybody so
if you're listening
apologize you can turn your radios back
up i'm going to talk at a normal volume
and at a normal voice register i hope
you're doing well thanks for joining us
this is the dr john daloni show where we
talk about your life mental health
relationships man i'm still kind of
tripping out a little bit
i came in a little hot what's up hey
everybody
i'll do it a little bit different i'm
going to restart ready
hey what's up good morning it's dr john
alone show if you're doing well
that sounded stupid too i'm just glad
that you're with us if you want to be on
this show i'd love to talk to you um the
world needs what
they may not need what you're thinking
about but they probably do right
somebody out there is struggling with
something that you're struggling with
and your vulnerability and bravery to
walk through it
on the air is a gift right so give me a
shout at one
eight four four six nine three thirty
two ninety one that's one
eight four four six nine three three two
nine one
or go to johndaloni.com show and you can
be
on the show fill out the form and we'd
love to have you on
so real quick we got an email last night
i won't make it us vs you i'm gonna make
this all about me
okay that was me to the booth
here's the email from janet
hello dr john the first time i heard you
say this i thought it was simply a
one-time mistake
i don't make a lot of one-time mistakes
i tend to do the same thing over and
over but i appreciate your heart janet
but you use the word frequently in its
cavalry army in parentheses
not calvary in parentheses where jesus
died
you don't need to send in the calvary
where jesus died but rather
the cavalry guns and horses and all that
stuff
hope you take this in the helpful spirit
with which it was offered
you might also note that the ph in the
word pamplet
is exactly that it's uh not
it's like it sounds like an f not a p i
just did it wrong
pamphlet pamphlet
not okay so now that i'm very popular
with your team i'll sign off blessings
to you
janet you know what janet blessings to
you you are very popular with the team
they were very happy with your email
because they
feel like they have been misaligned on
this show inappropriately as the grammar
police as the dress code police as the
hey will you put your bag down put your
things up clear up this thing let police
which they are but you janet you called
it out so here's the thing
i would like you all to take your
pamphlets
to the cavalry
where you will teach the army and those
who ride horses and shoot
guns and go to the alamo you'll teach
some things with your pamphlets
do not take your pamphlet to
calvary and then if you do you'll be
drowned
you might get drowned by the cavalry
if you go around reading your pamphlets
to everybody
i know i'm really making a great case
for why you should go to grad school
because you learn all your right words
you learn all the right words
so and here's another thing that's
driving me crazy today
i haven't got a haircut in a long time
and my friend buddy pointed out when we
lived together back in college that if i
don't get my hair cut
it grows into a perfect shell like a
helmet
and he used to call me chin strap and it
would just be like
and that was a reminder hey i'm gonna go
ahead and click your chin strap because
you look like you could run into the
side of a brick building with your
i see it's all slicked over like i'm
some kind of i don't know
gangster of some sort from 1844
with a bunch of gree i don't know greece
i want to be in social distortion so bad
i was
going to say the the jean jacket and the
poison shirt kind of play up the part
i like it my palm aid
did you not catch a subtle reference by
the uh clothing police
of which james is awesome i said i like
it you look like it's outsider chic
outsider chic follow me on instagram at
outsider chic slash
john deloney that's not really a thing
all right that's enough of that
i'm going to get a haircut this week and
i'm going to be able to run faster
because my head will be lighter
all right let's go to uh sarah in
bismarck north dakota
what's up sarah how are you hey i think
i just mispronounced that
is it bismarck yes it is
yes i can read thank you all right that
made me feel better about my life all
right so hey what's going on how are you
i'm good how are you good good good good
so how's how's it going what can i do to
help
um well i have a question about my
teenager i have a son who is 17.
he has an adhd diagnosis but we don't
have him on medication because
we tried a few different ones and had
really bad side effects from those
okay but anyway he's really struggling
in school right now he's
failing i think two classes
and these and a couple other ones and
then a c
but we just really really struggled with
him
in school and he just has no motivation
to want to do good in school
to do well and like we've tried
a lot of different things we've and it
used to work we only threatened to take
away his electronics or we would take
away his electronics take away his cell
phone and
he'd work you know do what he had to to
get his grades back up so he could get
his
stuff back and and now that doesn't even
work anymore and it just he just
doesn't wanna seem to understand why he
needs to
do good in school
and you know other things too i mean he
like he has no desire to
get his driver's license he doesn't seem
to need it he says and
i just i don't know how to get him
motivated i guess
so take me back to
your um take me back to
are you still married yep take me back
to you and your husband
um y'all's dating in your marriage what
was that like
well actually i i am divorced from
mason's dad
okay um i remarried when
uh mason was five okay and
if we're still married we have three
other children
so is mason the oldest mason's the
oldest yep
awesome so tell me about your
tell me about the dating life what was
it like being a single mom
dating with a young kid
well you know um it was great i actually
met my husband on match.com
and he was like the first person that i
really dated after mason's dad and it
was
even when we were emailing back and
forth like i just had a feeling that
that he was the one and here we are 12
years later
very cool so why did you and mason's dad
get divorced um well mason's dad and i
we were high school
sweethearts um and
so i guess i just kind of felt like the
expectation that we would get married
and i guess that's what i thought that i
wanted and
looked past a lot of other things um
thinking that eventually he was going to
grow up
and get past the wanting to go out all
the time and be the center of attention
all the time and ultimately he didn't
um he he is a people person and wants to
be out going doing seeing whatever and i
wanted to be a wife and a mom
and those two worlds didn't really go
very well together
he ended up having an affair
um we tried to kind of do some
counseling and stuff afterwards and
but everything was his way or the
highway so i kind of just
said okay that's fine gotcha so
well thank you for for being vulnerable
and walking me back there so how old was
mason when all that went on he
he was two okay and so
um as we work through this by the way
and this is for you and for every
listener
i've wrestled over the past five six
seven eight nine
years as we talk through these things
because it's hard to
be honest and it's hard to paint a full
picture that
offers hope and light without
people's natural tendency to want to
focus on
blame and shame does that make sense
yep so i want to paint a full picture
as i can in in you know just a few
minutes here
but i want to do that with your promise
that you
your your goal your emphasis your
you'll end this call with a smile on
your face looking forward
not trying to re-edit the story of the
past which is something you can't
re-edit is that cool
oh yeah absolutely awesome okay so
when did mason start checking out you
said you used to be able to
threaten him with things like i'm gonna
take this away or i'm gonna
you have to do this or else when did he
finally just say you know what i don't
care
um probably about a year
or so ago okay
talk to me about that um
well you know
yeah i think like his his sophomore year
we were still able to
kind of say hey you're going to
lose this or you need to do that but i
think you know once he
school stopped last year with kovid
and then he was home and
he actually even started out the school
year
our kids here did go back to school last
fall on a hybrid schedule so like every
other day
but they also had the option to do 100
home school
and so it gave mason the option to
choose which one
and he chose to do homeschool or 100
distance education or whatever and so
i would you know i would say that during
that time frame is kind of
it's gone downhill for sure yeah
so
what is something that mason loves that
he zones in on
and he will just lose time
um electronics um
talk to me right now it's reading on his
phone
okay talk to me about it what's he
reading
where does he go what kind of vortex
does he get into like talk me through
that
um well he pretty much stays in his room
unless it's mealtime and it's getting
harder to get him to come out for that
and he just he'll sit on his phone and
he just reads
he lays in bed last night i think he
fell asleep when he got home from school
and i went down to his room at nine
o'clock and
he was i woke him up i'm like mason
you're not going to sleep tonight
um so
and he i guess i think anime is kind of
what he's been reading okay
so um i'm gonna say some things that are
not very popular
and i want you to go with me for a
minute is that cool
sure all right so the most convincing
evidence i have read about
the development of adhd
i reject wholeheartedly that it's a
brain disorder
i reject wholeheartedly that a kid's
brain is broken
if they have adhd mainly because i am
a card-carrying member of that crew
it's not a dysfunction as as it is as
much a response
and if we're in another show um i've
actually been on other people's
shows if you will to discuss and argue
and debate
whether it's a genetic thing or this or
that
the most compelling research i have read
suggests
it is a natural response to maternal
stress
a chaotic early childhood
and a chaotic and or
power driven elementary school middle
school high school years
and so it not only doesn't surprise me
it paints me a picture that's both
sad and encouraging okay so hear me say
that
that when he was his youngest that it
the time that
a young child would need the most in i'm
going to keep going back to this one
word connection connection connection
the most connection you were dealing
with a
major trauma a person that you had loved
and hitched your wagon to
for years suddenly violated a core
covenant of yours
right yep and then you had this thing
called
trust that you trusted yourself and that
guy took that away from you
and the resulting tears and heartbreak
and let's
work on this in fights in his way
highways all those things
for a little two-year-old or
three-year-old or five-year-old
and then you introduce some other guy to
the picture who sounds like he's
wonderful and great i'll go with that
awesome
all of that is
is chaos for a little kid right not
right wrong or different well some of
it's not right but
it's chaos okay and so the brain becomes
scattered
to to use dr gabor mate's word it
becomes it picks up highly
um it picks up different things in the
environment it
locks in on some things and it
completely ignores others
all in this loop-de-loop t-loop it
becomes highly highly sensitive to
rejection
highly highly sensitive to am i valued
here
and here's where it's hard most parents
know
one technique and that is power that is
i am bigger than you i am
stronger than you i own your stuff so
you will do what i
want you'll do what i say or i will take
stuff away from you
i will withhold things from you whether
it's you can't play in little league or
you can't ride this bike or you can't
have your video games or whatever
i'm gonna take that away and that
actually works for a season
just because you're bigger i got bigger
muscles than you do right
and then you run into a wall where
there's always a tipping point
often it's when kids go to college for
the first time and they feel
quote unquote free and that freedom
translates to a kid who's struggling
with adhd is you don't have to do
anything
which then turns into i don't move i
just eat
i just play video games all day and then
the biochemistry
kicks in when your body's gotta move and
you gotta eat healthy and you gotta get
out and stop staring at screens and so
on and so forth right
so there's this power dynamic
where you're going to do what i say or
we're going to do x y and z
there's going to be a consequence and
we'll loop back to this because those
are important too
you do what i say oh there's going to be
consequences and it works and it works
and it works and then a pandemic hits
and then a kid gets a weird thing that
they've never had before which is called
control
i get to choose whether i go to school
or not i get to choose whether i'm
around other people or not
and since school for adhd kids is often
a failure factory it's often a reminder
about how you don't fit in
of course i'm gonna opt for home
which for an adhd kid whose brain is
screaming for connection
is you know it's a it's a death gong
from an old you know from an old kung fu
movie
it just rings the gong and all of a
sudden you know oh it's coming right
and then over time the same power
techniques they don't work anymore
and kids begin to just unhook i'm out
right and now you're faced with a 17
year old and i need you to know
there are millions in your situation
you're faced with a
17 year old who's just unplugged from
life and he's going to go down his own
rabbit holes because that's where he can
escape
and so the the challenge you have
in a short order is he a senior or a
junior
a junior a junior okay so
you have a year and a half or you've got
a little more than a year
and it you'll have your work cut out for
you okay and it's going to depend on
how much how far down the rabbit hole
you want to go and it's going to depend
on
you being able to transition from a
short-term game to a long-term game
okay the goal here is to
over-connect with him to let him know he
has not only value but he's got a role
in this house and that role the house
the house ecosystem functions only
because he's in it
and that when he opts out when he
chooses to
not do his academic work when he chooses
to not help around the house
then the system falls down without him
not
there is an operating system that we are
making you be a part of
and if you don't we're going to take
things that you love away from you okay
and so what does that actually look like
okay so let me just pause right here is
any of this ringing true
or do you think i sound like a hippie
actually it sounds very interesting okay
and here's the thing that stinks parents
were
20 years ago 15 years ago parents were
told how your kids got adhd they've got
a brain disorder here's some medicine
and it's going to fix them
and the crappy part about most
medications for adhd is their speed
and they work for everybody for a short
term right
we all know what it's like to wake up i
mean to not sleep and then we just
mainline coffee it'll prop you up till
about noon right
and then you've got a hard decision to
make am i not going to sleep tonight or
am i going to
just crash in the afternoon that's
that's the trajectory of a kid
right and so good for you guys for
recognizing the side effects but then
you're left with what do we do now okay
so here's what i want you to start
thinking through right
do you want your son to grow and learn
or do you want him to do right
and what i want to convince you of or
hope you will get is i can't convince
you of it
is growing and learning is going to end
up
in him living the right way okay and
he's gonna
a rough road to hoe i do i still do
the other night as i was laying down to
go to bed
my wife said and i quote and we've been
together 20 something years
i got a job i go to every day i got
health insurance okay so i want you to
know the future's bright for your son
but she said as i'm getting into bed hey
are you doing okay
and i said yeah why do you think that
and she said well just look around in
our room
and whenever the room starts to look
like this i know you're not doing okay
to which then i got all huffy and puffy
and i got out of bed i was so tired and
i cleaned the room and i was like i'll
just take five minutes to do this
it took like 45 minutes because it was
such a train wreck
and so i need you to know that it's
still something i'm working on to this
day
okay and it's become i've
found people to connect with not that
try to beat me into submission
okay so here's a couple of things you
can do
number one i would take your son out
just to you
get him off site get him out of your
house and take him somewhere
like the joke on this show is always
take somebody to breakfast i like
breakfast because people are
awake and they're not exhausted and
they're not trying to text with their
friends at 10 o'clock at night
and just get a pulse on him see how he's
like doing how does he feel what's going
on
and let him know hey i've tried to do
this
one thing this way for so long i'm sorry
it's not working and i'm much more
interested in loving you
than having your electronics at the top
of my closet
so i'm going to pause right there is the
idea of going and being vulnerable with
your son
is that hard is that something you've
already tried is that something you're
willing to do
um well you know we've um we've tried
throughout the years to do
one-on-ones with all four of the kids
and
we're kind of we're not consistent with
it at all
um but i mean it's definitely something
that we
have on our radar and would like to do
more of for sure
okay does he have a good relationship
with his stepdad
um it's kind of kind of hit and miss
okay does he still is he still connected
to his
birth dad um yeah
he but his his
birth dad lives um in las vegas
okay so okay he doesn't see him all that
often
so here's what i want you to do i want
you just you
i want you to ride out on a piece of
paper take some time i want you to take
a couple hours to do this
i want you to remember the things about
your son that you love
funny memories you all have together
from the past
things that you love about him quirks
silly things when he makes you double
over with laughter
when you thought he was going to tank
something and he came through in the
clutch whatever that may be
he's a great artist he is silly he's and
these can range the all
17 years of his life
i want you to write those down and i
want you to take him out to breakfast
and say i'm your mom you have to listen
to me tell you this stuff
okay and he'll roll his eyes and be like
mommy and you got to make him turn his
phone off put his phone in your purse
mum i don't want to be no i'm going to
say some things to you
and it's going to start with i love you
and i've been trying to show you i love
you by trying to make you get good
grades
and i'm sorry i really really want you
to get good grades because i know you're
super smart and i want you to be
accomplished i want you to achieve great
things
but i've gone about it by taking stuff
away from you
first instead of connecting with you
first
and then i want you to ask him how he's
doing how are things going how are you
feeling
and then ultimately here's the ultimate
goal here okay
number one you've got to get him to buy
into your home system
how your home works that he's a vital
member of that place
that it can't work without him and that
when he chooses
to not be a part of it his his decision
impacts other people
right it's purpose it's value it's
connection
okay and so at some point after he knows
you're connected and he knows hey you
know what
you're 17 if you're gonna fail you're
gonna be in summer school all summer
and you're gonna have to repeat your
senior year
you get to choose to do that you're 17.
right not under my roof i can just hear
the listeners right now
not under my roof i'm taking away all
the electronics
and what i want to point you to is how's
that working out
it's not it's not he's going down a
deeper and deeper and deeper hole
could you constrict him so much
absolutely
you could cut off all power all internet
you could take us all electronics away
and he'll be he'll be a thousand miles
away from you standing right next to you
holding your hand
okay yeah we've done that there you go
it doesn't work
okay people change that you can
you can compress and power somebody
through something
but at the end of the day you're gonna
have to change their heart through
connectivity okay
and so i want you and your whole family
at some point and this is gonna maybe be
a month or two down the road
he's gotta buy back in that you're all
in on his team okay
here's what that's going to be it's
going to be weird i want you a couple of
nights a week to go lay in bed with him
in the evening
go lay next to him in that disgusting
bed that's probably smells and it's full
of sand and all kind of stuff
insane oh yeah it's hey it's gross
i did it with my 11 year old son last
night and i'm not the cleanest guy
and it was oh my gosh
okay but i want you to hold his hand and
say uh i'm your mom and you have to hold
my hand he's gonna go
mom it's good nope you're holding my
hand
okay you don't have to look him in the
eye because that's hard for a 17 year
old and that may be hard for you
i want you to lay by him and say you
have to tell me three things about your
day
three things that were crappy and three
things that were awesome
and here's what we're doing we are
rebuilding connection from the floor up
and you're going first
and my gut tells me is that you don't
know how to do this either
and so you're gonna have to practice
along the way and the more you tell them
i think this is weird and vulnerable but
i think
i miss you not i think this is the right
thing to do
to help your adhd no i miss you you're
my son i love you
and you start from there and then at
some point you're gonna as a family say
hey we're gonna develop the family rules
all the kids around the table everyone's
gonna vote we're all in this
and that's how you get buy-in so that
when he chooses to just sit in his house
like
i mean sit in his room and not
participate in the family
he's opting he is choosing to let the
family system fall down
right i want you and your husband to go
somewhere and talk about
what kind of outside of the bedroom
experience are we creating that our kids
want to go hide from us
are we just coming home and plopping on
the couch and watching tv ourselves
are we just sitting around arguing are
we telling everybody get this clean up
this do this do that all that
or are we having a laughing family do we
go outside and run around the front yard
are we throwing food at each other not
that you have food fights but is it an
environment that kids want to be a part
of where they see their parents as
humans not as robots
well i know mason will say that he stays
in his room because his
siblings are too loud okay
well hey here's the thing a key factor
or a key thing of adhd is
sensitivity and it makes people nuts and
you'll look at them and go what do you
mean sensitive you're watching anime
blowing out the rods and cones in your
eyes and you've got headphones on 24 7
listening to house music and you're you
know you're going deaf
it just it just depends on certain
people at certain times
i sit in my house and i think it feels
like elephants are running around and i
look around and it's an 11 year old and
a five-year-old
and they're just laughing having fun so
i have to remember the problem is me and
so that's when
you tell him i want you to be a part of
this family
if they're being too loud i want him to
learn some skills not
not disconnection and running away he
can learn some skills to say
hey guys let's color instead let's do
something let's engage that
the problem not run away from it not
power through it right
i want you guys to have hard
conversations in the coming months about
sleep
about nutrition about physical space i
want you to clean your room a lot of
kids with adhd especially 17 year olds
their rooms are
nightmarish right oh my gosh we
just took three garbage bags full of
stuff out of his room it was awful
awesome well i'm glad you did that
hopefully it wasn't a fight
hopefully it goes back to that don't
forget to remember right
there's nothing better for an adhd kid
to wake up in a room full of order
and it's clean that's that's that makes
an adhd soul
breathe and the adhd soul forgets to
clean up the room every day
right it's maddening right
and so it's that don't forget to
remember my wife tells me that
when we go out to eat and i'm about to
just unload on some food she'll say hey
don't
just gently don't forget to remember
she's not gonna lecture me don't eat
that because then i'm gonna get all up
mad
why do you always do that she doesn't
because she doesn't pull away she just
gently says hey don't forget to remember
and i know that she's saying don't
forget to remember that you're not going
to sleep tonight if you eat 11 pieces of
pizza
don't forget to remember that if you
have more beers you're going to snore
all night you're not going to sleep you
can feel terrible tomorrow
don't forget to remember and then i go
oh yeah
i was about to forget how bad tomorrow's
going to be if i don't live into this
now
but listen she's only allowed to do that
because
she leans into not away from
she doesn't lecture she loves she
doesn't try to power through
she tries to connect all of this with
the 17 year old though starts with you
saying i'm sorry
it starts with you saying i've wanted
the best for you and i didn't have the
right tools in my toolkit so we're going
to learn how to do this together
i want to direct you to what i think is
the masterpiece the seminal work on adhd
it's called scattered
by dr gabor mate m-a-t-e and we'll link
to it in the show notes here
it's the masterpiece and it's a hard
read it's a hard read
my wife wept through a lot of it right
um
because you start to take ownership of
the ecosystem that's in your home
and we've had to work through like me
it's not your fault it's just what we
know it's just what we know
and let's work on this together and it's
been a magical transition in my house
okay it's called scattered by gabor mate
parents whose kids are struggling with
adhd number one
go back and look at the ecosystem the
kid developed in
number two look at how you are trying to
get them to do what you want them to do
is it through power
is it through coercion is it through i'm
just gonna medicate you
or is it through connection
and purpose and what do you love what do
you love
right what like what do you love and i'm
gonna draw connections if your kid
loves soccer and obsessed with soccer
just wants to play soccer never wants to
do homework
we're going to draw connections between
soccer man you can do hard things
you're really good at this and look at
that
i want you to apply those same skills in
the classroom right because in this
house we all
value responsibility right
that's a lot thank you so much for the
call um man
thank you so so much for that call sarah
i get so many calls about adhd
if you've got more more questions on it
give me a call
um i want us to begin to approach this
through connection not through power and
coercion
thank you so so much for the call and by
the way i'm not a hippie
i'm a i'm not
i just want you to always go back and
ask yourself this one question
is what i'm doing making my life better
am i actually solving this problem
we just need to do it faster and harder
and louder often
you're not right often you're not right
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to betterhelp.com for 10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
take care of yourself start today all
right let's go to sasha in
carson city what's up how we doing
hey dr john it's so good to talk to you
too hey did i say your name right
sacha sasha got it
beautiful beautiful name all right so
what's up how can i help
oh my goodness well how much time do you
have i have 11 hours
go this is a special podcast edition
um okay so i reached out to you all a
huge fan by the way
um love all the ramsey personalities
love your show
thank you um reached out because i heard
from my mom recently
she had a request of my husband and i
to help her open up a um a credit union
account
and this is um special for people who
it's a credit union who
caters to people in the military okay so
are you in the military my my husband is
in the military
okay yes and um so
by sort of default she would be able to
benefit from
what the credit union has to offer so
she reached out to me
kind of out of nowhere asking if
um we were a member and couldn't help
her open an account
is that a little bit shady
or is that normal okay for me it's
i my knee-jerk reaction was oh
what i i was
a little i mean that sounds like when i
used to ask people
to be my girlfriend in middle school and
their first reaction was oh
so yeah been there on the other side of
that one sasha thanks for kicking me
while i'm down
okay yeah started to bring that back no
it's good so
why don't you trust your gut
i do i do trust my gut my my real
struggle
is you know how do i kind of i guess
reject
her request and i know it's not going to
go well i'm
feeling a little guilty and a little
petty about it
but my deep down just does not feel
right
okay so here's what stinks man parents
often have the problems
and kids are forced to solve them
right that sounds like an old line check
out the hook while the dj revolves it
that's right that's that online
your parents have the problems right and
kids have to solve them
and that i hate that because it should
not be that way parents should be mature
and grown up and ethical
and honest and they're just a lot of
times not
and so here's what's awesome about this
call
i could tell you're really smart and
you're kind
and you're honest
and so it's it's nice it doesn't hurt me
very well but
no the fact that your first your first
thought when asked to do something from
somebody that you want to please
and that you want to respect and honor
and they ask you to do something that's
a wee bit shady
that is using a military benefit for
their
their good right yeah your first thought
was
no i might do that right it wasn't yeah
let's see how we can gain the system for
you
um here's what sucks about boundaries
you've got to draw them and you can't
hold the outcome
you can't be responsible for the
consequences of your boundaries
and so you're going to feel guilty
you've already said it
but it's your mom acting immature and
not being honest
right yeah and yeah here's what i'd
rather you do
i would rather you hold a strong
boundary
trust yourself because you're right hold
the boundary and grieve the loss of the
mother that you fantasize about
then you know
bend the rules here and then not be
forced to
like not be forced to deal with the
reality
your mom's using you your mom's using
your husband
right yeah yeah
yeah definitely i mean you you said a
couple times the word boundaries and
that's really the underlying issue
there's been a number of times where
especially in like a financial
situation there's been some boundaries
that have been kind of
a little watery or muddy and so that's
really why i'm just you know if it were
maybe a good friend and
the rules applied i would seriously
consider it but
just we haven't had the best like
boundaries when it comes to finances
so how old are you um i am about to be
40. okay and how long have you been
married
um let's see it's been about seven
months now
oh wow so you're in it now okay is his
first marriage second marriage
first marriage we are also about to have
our first baby
congratulations okay so listen
it is the i can't tell you how important
it is
that you and your brand new husband
go somewhere get together and
write out on paper your boundaries for
your new relationship
your marriage and you're about to be
parents
if you thought mom was shady before oh
man
it's about to get awesome okay yeah
i mean some of that some of that is
definitely coming up and i i promised
myself i didn't want to call here
and bash her you know she's no no she's
obviously done the best she can
absolutely it's not a bashing it's a
it's a
okay and there's a difference between
saying
i hate you you're an idiot you're a
[ __ ] and
you are not good with money and i can't
allow that into my new young family
yeah right one is dishonoring and
gossipy and just trashing somebody to
make you
prop you up and make you feel better one
is calling a spade a spade
right yeah there's a lot of people in my
life that i love dearly that i would
never hire right
a lot of folks that i talk to somewhat
regularly that make me laugh so hard
i don't know if my guts will ever work
again that i would not leave my kid with
right right so it doesn't have to be
mutually exclusive
you do have to be wise
and here's the thing if you're not wise
and you choose to
duct tape over relationship issues
you're on a bullet train towards
resentment
yeah i can definitely i when i imagine
saying yes or
kind of giving in i i do feel that sort
of resentment like okay well i'll help
you with this but like
where were you at the baby shower and
like why can't we just talk about the
baby coming and
why does it have to be about a bank
account you know yeah
um and it may be it may be that she
wants to open a bank account so she can
put money into it for your kid
right who knows who knows probably not
but it's fun to dream right
um here's the thing you're wise
and you're a good person so i tell you
that to tell you trust yourself
and you live in a world where women are
told don't trust your intuition
i'm telling you to trust yours and trust
your new marriage
and trust that impulse that says that's
not a good idea
and then get some get some time away
with your husband
plan and dream write down these
boundaries
and then hold them firm and then also be
loving to your mom too
and what's that mean that means be clear
and direct and not passive-aggressive
yes yeah right go to coffee with her
or if she's too far away and just
talking on the phone sounds like you all
living somewhat in the same area
go to coffee with her and say hey mom
i'm not gonna i can't use military
benefits
for somebody who's um not like
who doesn't apply they don't apply to i
can't do that i'm not gonna do that
well i think i'm not mom we're not doing
that
okay yeah you can go get your own
checking account or your own
credit union account when you want to go
get your credit union account
i'm not gonna do that yeah and then you
move on to the next thing
and if she chooses to throw a temper
tantrum on that that's a decision that
she's making
not that you made right that's true
yep and it's coming times a thousand
why don't you let me see my baby i want
to come see my grandkid it's my
grandbaby why don't y'all just go out
and i'm gonna hey i'm gonna got a new
boyfriend i'm gonna bring over to
whatever the thing is right right right
get those things down now all right
yeah that's a good idea okay you're
what you want has value the right things
are the right things
and you're gonna have to practice
holding those boundaries and here's
what's hard about boundaries
it takes so much energy and courage to
lay them out there
that we want everyone to just honor them
like it was so hard to build this fence
why why'd you knock it down or why'd you
keep bashing your head against it
or why are you throwing things over it
at me trying to make it my fault that i
wanted to keep my family safe
always remember the the practice of
developing boundaries is hard
the practice of building boundaries and
setting them up is really hard
and then when people try to knock them
down it hurts
all of that is part of boundaries it is
always in the short term easier just to
be like all right whatever dude
it's easy whatever and it always comes
back to bite you
always comes back to bite you you're
awesome sasha congratulations on new
marriage
thank your husband for his service for
our country
enjoy being a mom it's going to be
awesome and
man build those boundaries all right so
we're going to wrap up today's show i
took a long time on that first call so
we're going to wrap it up today
um yeah we're doing it
i remember being a young young child
back in 1988 for some of you listening
to that makes me like a thousand years
old
i remember this song came on i think it
has a xylophone intro if i'm not
mistaken
that's embarrassing but it was the 80s
so we'll go with it
this is the first band i ever saw live
in concert when i was
a wee little lad i think it was peter
cetera was there singers that right
anyway that's off the chicago 19 album
imagine an awesome awesome xylophone
intro
and then this when you called me up this
morning
told me about the new love you found i
said i'm happy for you
i'm really happy for you you found
someone else i guess i won't be coming
around i guess it's over baby
it's really over baby whoa
and from what you said i know you've
gotten over me it'll never be the way it
used to be so if it's got to be this way
don't worry baby i can take the news
okay
but if you see me walking by and the
tears are in my eyes
look away baby look away oh my gosh
that's so good
i'll i love you but i can't look you in
the eye
if we meet on the street someday and i
don't know what to say look away baby
look away don't look at me
i don't want you to see me this way off
the 1988
song by chicago called look away if you
see me walking by and the tears are in
my eye
look away this is the dr john dolone's
show
you